[Music]
in blind shooting news we got the rhythm
going
is it a spell out secret or you go
secret yes I mean like this calm Mara
Megamall calm you get that the barbel
brigade calm you know what's your
cooking section called again mana hungry
we review food and cook I don't know why
that [ __ ] cracked me the [ __ ] up dude
it's just because his branding is the
strongest out of all of us watching your
videos in his videos guys branding is
hot point to do this thing called a
one-handed chef because remember I used
to fill yeah so I try to cook with just
one hand obviously is gonna [ __ ] up but
then my challenge was to try to complete
the meal with only one hand while I'm
recording with the other try making
dumplings on one hand it was I it took
much longer than dude just [ __ ]
deep-fry one-handed yeah chopping
vegetables was the hardest with one hand
submitted by phone of apples droids
sorry I got that I got the tennis West
Virginia is passing a law to allow
legally blind persons to hunt with
adaptive equipment adaptive equipment
like there's someone else's eyeball on
the gun no they got one of these things
in their ears
now you can hear the wave out there
blind
that's why it's funny cuz it does even
work yeah it's just extra equipment so
now they could hear even more so then
now it's like there it makes up for
their yeah they could be a bad dog do
when they were when that guy was going
around talking about he give you back a
location is it it was supposed to be
really cool I laughed my ass off because
this dude was just out of the public
there's a black dolphins and whales and
whales
I wonder well there's just one video
there's this one black hit that does
this like echolocation stuff wall and he
beatboxing do roller she [ __ ]
rollerblades rollerblades he's blind
[Laughter]
it's like all over the place right
trying to listen in front of that front
prime from thinking yeah but it's just
you know you know they're blind because
they have that blind swagger to them you
know this kid was rollerblading through
traffic yeah that was the crazy part cuz
they're showing the b-roll and then I'm
like and there's just cars going and
he's just like he had his friend who's
not blind they play video games and he
gets his ass kicked this is not blind
friend and in the news was asking him
how does it feel when he beats you you
got picked by a blind guy I'm like damn
who must really suck at games but he's
playing like call of duty and I guess
you can hear what rooms he's in and
stuff
see something about that guy this wine
game right he's not a Josh man good
vision he's [ __ ] lying dude no but so
the trippy thing about this story is
that it's already legal for blind people
to get a hunting license give me some
more behind that yeah cuz it just sounds
like because there's nothing that is
stated in order for them that they can't
get it so because of that there's no
like prereqs what like you gotta have
like a legal guardian right like some
sort of assistant to guide you well
that's the thing it's illegal to use
adaptive equipment right now and so
there's this bill that they're trying to
make it legal so the way they describe
it here is another place the gun it will
have since acquiring the target
selecting the target identifying the
target sighting the target and then the
person that is blind will be pulling the
trigger but the way that they're
electing that sought the target is
through a laser so they're saying that
this laser like this equipment that
allows blind people to hunt hunt is
illegal as of now as it should be for
sure people are Americans too yeah
nothing that prohibits a blind person
from obtaining a hunting license okay
that is what well I think because when
they were doing that they weren't
thinking that blind people would want to
hunt so one of the examples here is that
like one of the one of the people trying
to push this bill they're saying that he
meant senator he met know he met some
constituent he was a hunter who could
see and then he went blind in a hunting
accident
he still hunts with this illegal
adaptive equipment so it's trying to be
like oh they'll continue to all I'm
gonna say there's probably someone out
there that's like super sick with
hunting skills but they're blind like
that black blind kung fu masters or some
[ __ ] that we don't know about you're
gonna be like they don't know it's like
there's probably some like hillbilly
dude in West Virginia with one tooth and
he's like the
as hunter but he's actually blind and
you can just feel what the Ducks are
overall with no t-shirt I bet you
there's like a world-renowned [ __ ]
hunter and he lives out in the hills all
by himself and [ __ ] what is this like
illegal adaptive equipment though that's
that's what I'm tripping out of but it's
like what technology exists that's gonna
guide a blind person to know where to
shoot is it just like there is
technology out there already though that
I forgot the name of it but then as soon
as it it's it's got its sights on its
target it automatically pulls so all you
guys do is line it up how do you know
like it actually like bull's eye target
we're like an animal or animals
what is it differentiate between human
and Anna
no it was no human there but I watched a
video of how it worked what if it's a
human dressed up as an animal then
they're [ __ ] I guess not do i watch
the video too and you can set the target
as human or animal and maybe like when
they create the stop yeah so when they
create the scope like they're just the
scope and optics company right it's like
like cameras they don't know if we're
gonna shoot pornos or [ __ ] shoe vlogs
with family vlogs with it so they're
just doing their job oh for both but
they they take it and uh I think you can
even calculate elevation windage
humidity like all that stuff it's almost
to the point where it takes years of
training of like a sharpshooter it takes
it all out and it just be done through
the sculpt and makes all the adjustments
yep so that's probably what might be
going on here and they might not be they
might be legally blind but they not it's
not like maybe really blind there's
people who are legally blind right right
right
because you'll see boy yeah is that even
fun though if you're that blind guy
right and you have that [ __ ] laser
technology
[Laughter]
good method Buffalo and then the other
blind is a [ __ ] I actually got
skills you just got that laser [ __ ]
there's it takes the reward out of
hunting well I think like it's different
for somebody who never had that option
before to have that option so that's
probably it's it's something better than
nothing could you just lie to him but
yeah you had the Buffalo rather than the
adaptive equipment I would feel like you
know they would have to be kind of a
prerequisite of you have to be with a
guide who like kind of watch it through
it along with the adaptive equipment I
hope so man yeah but what if these blind
people are way more capable than we ever
worked because they just grew up in the
forest and [ __ ] yeah maybe the survivors
on bird box
well they work at the very end yeah
that's true no [ __ ] what kept saying
that so I'm like now my times too
precious what was that movie where she
showed her ass she sold her movie is
that I don't know with Ryan Reynolds
like oh the proposal oh she showed her
ass dude really
she's like covering her chest in her ass
if I don't like it when the movies where
you see the butt and then it's like just
a little cracker yeah it's like I want
to see some real ass spread that [ __ ] an
[ __ ] cause he's on [ __ ] so you're
liking big butts it's just cuz you want
to see their [ __ ]
no what he likes is like he likes the
ass but then he could see that I like
that - no
like that's it oh so you want to see the
camel toe I want to see that camel toe I
didn't in the movies - most of these
ladies really Zack puts the Buzzi dude
who got the best booty in the game right
now this summer summer what's your name
summary summary oh I was thinking I was
looking I was thinking for actors yeah
but she should her booty is nice that's
Instagram oh that's different their
whole forte is ass yeah she bought their
specialists actors a little bit
different cuz I got that yeah other
skills makeup Byul maybe you just go
field is that a bad I do with chuck and
Larry was she yes I have never been
attracted to a girl at seventh heaven in
my life oh yeah because she looks
healthy or most actresses look a little
too skinny so then when their clothes
come off it looks like a grandma's ass
you know it's all droopy it's like I'm
pretty sure there's more muscle and fat
that could fit in there right because
the skin prepares for it but it just
looks like this looks like this see what
I'm doing right here that's what it
looks like - elbows going to rise oh
that's the one you see right now bro
seventh heaven
like that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's our outro
[Music]
[Music]